temps
le désert de gobi en mongolie une
véritable fournaise en était une
glacière désolé en hiver mais cet
endroit austère cache sous ces sables le
plus terrible secret de l'histoire de
l'évolution un incroyable gisement de
dinosaures fossiles qui représente le
berceau de l'humanité
en 1922 le désert de gobi livrera son
secret à un seul homme visionnaire et
courageux
roj chapman en 12 les mongols le
considérer comme un chasseur de dragons
pour le reste du monde
chapman 12 était cet explorateur
américain audacieux qui a osé percer les
secrets du désert de gobi
manhattan au début des années folles
ville synonyme d'ambition ou les
aristocrates cherche le moyen le plus à
la mode de placer les millions de
dollars dont ils ne savent que faire
beaucoup d'entre eux choisissent comme
bénéficiaire le muséum américain
d'histoire naturelle
le muséum est alors administrée par and
we fuck phil osborn et possède la plus
belle collection de dinosaures fossiles
au monde
ce conservateur et paléontologue de
talent a fait de son muséum un
chef-d'oeuvre en prenant le monde comme
toile de fond
osbourne dépêche ces explorateurs vers
les destinations les plus exotiques du
pôle nord aux forêts équatoriales
les scientifiques qui l'envoie sur le
terrain reviennent en véritable
superstar l'un de ses plus brillants
protéger n'est autre que rory chapman
jews andrews est parti à la recherche
des baleines grises et des tigres d'asie
et à effectuer des expéditions quatre
coins du monde pour le compte du très
célèbre museum new yorkais
mais andrews est fasciné plus que tout
au monde par cette terre lointaine et
inexplorée la mongolie il en a eu un
aperçu durant la première guerre
mondiale lorsque les états unis
l'avaient envoyé en asie comme espion
son unique désir et de retourner dans
cette partie du monde vaste et désolé en
tant que scientifique
c'est en 1920 quand jude rencontre le
seul américain qui partage sa
fascination pour la mongolie
elle lui fait fils deux bornes osbourne
a émis l'hypothèse que la mongolie était
le berceau des mammifères le jardin
d'éden de l'évolution world chapman 12
souhaite le prouver selon le borgne
c'est en mongolie que les animaux à sang
chaud ont succédé aux dinosaures les
premiers félins les mammouths les
éléphants il croit même que c'est là que
sont apparus les premiers hommes
osbourne pense que les animaux
préhistoriques ont quitté le plateau
style de gobi pour se diriger à l'ouest
vers l'europe et l'afrique au sud vers
l'asie et à l'est vers les amériques le
prouver reviendrait à résoudre l'un des
plus grands mystères de la vie sur terre
c'est une idée fixe pour eux se bornent
andrew sera envoyé en mongolie
ce travail s'avérera l'oeuvre de toute
une vie pour cet explorateur qui 14 ans
plus tôt n'était encore qu'un jeune
passionné venu du wisconsin employé
comme agent d'entretien par le muséum la
proposition dans 12 est stupéfiante
une expédition de cinq ans coûtant 250
mille dollars une somme astronomique le
muséum seul ne peut pas couvrir mais en
12 est introduit dans la haute société
sa femme yvette est connu quant aux
relations deux bornes
elle facilite la tâche ma seule chance
c'est de faire de cette expédition une
expédition pour la haute société
la société new yorkaise suit aveuglément
un homme en vue si quelqu'un comme
monsieur morgan bonne d'exemple elle
pensera qu'il faut limiter pour être à
la mode
le banquier de jp morgan est donc la
première cible
chose étonnante mangane accepte
immédiatement de faire don de 50 mille
dollars ce qui équivaudrait aujourd'hui
à plusieurs millions
pendant deux ans la collecte de fonds ne
permet pas en blouse de partir sur le
terrain mais elle fait parler de lui
oh
personne n'a jamais mené une telle
expédition il y allait tous songent à
meaux il parcourait au maximum 30 km par
jour
nous allons utiliser des voitures
nous couvrirons 150 km par jour et selon
mes estimations
nous parcourons autant en une saison que
ce que les expéditions précédentes ont
parcouru en dix c'est pour ça que vous
devez fond c'est maintenant parfois je
me donnerai pour grignoter des biscuits
boire du lait est allé me coucher juste
après au lieu de manger du caviar de la
soupe de tortue et du canard haute et
l'esprit d'aventuré dans l'air dix mille
personnes écrivent ça en 12
ils veulent se joindre à l'expédition en
mongolie cher monsieur en rose je vous
demande que dis-je je vous supplie de me
laisser vous accompagner dans votre
dangereux et l'aïe peut-elle organiser
une expédition en devenir membre
chez 30 ans si vous me répondez naveau
kepa pour refuser le fait que je suis un
bon vieux ou d'un coiffeur pour votre
expédition en 1921 en 12 a réuni les
deux cent cinquante mille dollars
cette somme est suffisant pour acheter
l'équipement de la plus vaste expédition
jamais organisée une équipe de
chercheurs étudiera la géologie le
climat de la mongolie le but de
l'expédition sera de trouver les traces
des premiers mammifères et de l'homme
préhistorique
l'expédition sera basé à pékin
l'ancienne capitale impériale de la
chine aujourd'hui connu sous le nom de
beijing
pour l'heure cette ville chaotique que
née la contestation d'un pitoyable
seigneurs de la guerre en 12 homme
raffiné acquiert l'une des résidences
les plus élégantes de pékin
oh
yvette andrews accompagnera son mari en
mongolie leur fils georges sera élevé
dans le palais le palais avait autrefois
appartenu un prince mandchoue qui était
si important qu'il avait trente et une
concubine il y avait cent soixante et
une chambre mon père avait trouvé que
c'était un bon point de départ
il a fait construire en laboratoire il a
beaucoup travaillé pour accélérer les
recherches
c'est à partir de pékin quand 12 décide
d'emmener son équipe de 26 personnes
vers les terres désolées de mongolie
avec un moyen de transport jusque là
inconnu du désert la voiture
l'expédition disposera d'une armada de
voitures en 12 ne s'est pourtant pas si
les véhicules supporteront une saison
entière dans le désert de gobi des
montagnes des rivières du sable et des
roches et voilà le paysage de l'ouest du
désert de gobi
il n'y a pas de garage au coin de la rue
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas de coin de rue
sept mille six cents litre d'essence et
de pétrole devront être acheminées à dos
de chameau et déposé à des endroits
stratégiques tout au long du parcours
andrews décide de confier cette tâche un
chamelier mongol du nom de merine mais
alors que la caravane pénètre dans le
désert rien ne prouve qu'en 12 revers à
l'essence ou même mérine
en avril 1922 l'équipe de géologues
zoologue cartographes et paléontologue
s'apprête à travailler sous la houlette
du scientifique
walter grainger c'était le numéro 2 de
l'expédition
le paléontologue en chef et le
responsable scientifique de l'expédition
c'était un homme extraordinaire un peu
un père pour nous un homme extrêmement
gentil reuil et lui s'entendaient très
bien
il était aux antipodes l'un de l'autre
et ensemble ils faisaient du bon boulot
en 12 engage un cinéaste hollywoodien du
nom de djibi tchèque fraude pour filmer
l'évolution de l'expédition en 12ème les
fossiles mais il aime également la
publicité
alors que les chameaux sont déjà partis
transportant le carburant et les vivres
les voitures transporteront le matériel
scientifique les tentes les réchauds et
les armes
ces dernières seront nécessaires pour
ramener des spécimens d'animaux et se
protéger dans un pays déchiré par la
guerre
le 17 avril notre première expédition en
direction de la mongolie kit pékin après
des années de préparation des mois
d'efforts et de doutes sont enfin
derrière nous le travail sur le terrain
enfin commencer
tout d'abord les voitures sont acheminés
en train depuis pékin jusqu'au plateau
de mongolie
au dessus de nos têtes se dessine un
escarpement de basalte couronnée par la
grande muraille qui s'étire sinueuse
entre la chine et la mongolie
nos voitures ont gagné le sommet du
dernier versants escarpés et ont franchi
le passage étroit à travers la muraille
devant nos yeux c'est en une terre de
désert flamboyant dansant dans un mirage
la mongolie est une terre de mystères de
paradoxes et de promesses
un fougueux explorateur américain est en
train d'introduire la technologie du
xxème siècle dans un pays médiévale
poussé par ce défi scientifique japan on
june s'est rendu au bout du monde
au printemps 1922 le scientifique et
aventurier japan on june men
l'expédition la plus importante jamais
entreprise dans le désert de gobi l'une
des régions les plus désolé et paraît-il
les plus arides du monde dès le premier
jour en mongolie une boue impraticable
contrarie l'expédition
le premier jour rien ne va jamais comme
on veut
si seulement on pouvait commencer tout
de suite à partir du 2ème tous les
hommes engagés dans la course étaient
trempés jusqu'aux os couverts de boue et
tremblait de froid
pourtant personne ne se plaignait tous
plaisantait en disant que leur premier
jour aux confins du désert de gobi était
marqué par la boue et la pluie
alors qu'il avance dans le désert ils
font une découverte macabre les
ossements de soldats chinois massacrés
pendant la guerre qui l'opposé aux
forces russes
un an auparavant
leurs manteaux en peau de mouton et
leurs pantalons contenait encore le roux
dont certains avaient été soigneusement
nettoyés par lui loue et les corbeaux
les ossements sont la preuve que les
adversaires se livrent une bataille sans
merci pour acquérir ce pays stérile rôle
chapman and blues et son expédition sans
fond stocker du désert voici un colloque
de calibre 38 utilisés par la police que
mon père portait lors de cette
expédition ne savait pas seulement pour
faire beau mais pour se défendre
celui ci possède trois encoches les
personnes que mon père a tués étaient
des bandits qui essayait de lui barrer
la route
ils lui ont tiré dessus et mon père a
riposté il en a eu trois et vous
souhaite un bon tireur
l'expédition se dirige vers l'est vers
une région éloignée
irène d'assaut
chemin faisant
walter grainger localise un site qu'ils
pensent fossilifère il envoie des hommes
pour préparer les fouilles
andrews est habile quand un peu plus
loin 24 avril 1922 date quand jude n'est
pas prêt d'oublier les géologues sont
entrés dans le camp avec fracas les yeux
de walter granger brille est il sorti de
sa poche des fragments d'os dont une
dans de titane aux terres il avance à sa
main roj
nous avons réussi il y un gisement de
fossiles nous avons ramassé 25 kg d'os
en une heure
grainger a trouvé une dent de titane aux
terres mammifères disparus dont on avait
retrouvé les traces qu en amérique du
nord voisin du rhinocéros cet animal
mesurait deux mètres quarante au niveau
des épaules le lendemain walter grainger
fait une découverte encore plus
étonnante grainger était occupé à
dégager le tibia d'un grand dinosaure
je vis un énorme hausse magnifiquement
préservé et dont les contours dans la
roche était nette
nous avions bel et bien trouvé un
gisement de dinosaures le titane aux
terres est un mammifère vieux de 38
millions d'années l'os appartenait au
premier dinosaure découvert par des
scientifiques dans le désert de gobi la
découverte d'une dent de titane aux ter
et d'un tibia de dinosaures sur les
premiers éléments permettant de
corroborer la thèse selon laquelle
l'asie est le berceau de la vie sur
terre
mais c'est maintenant juste au moment de
cette découverte quand josé sa femme
doivent se rendre au point de
rendez-vous où va se jouer l'existence
même de l'expédition
c'est plus au nord que la caravane
conduite par mme erin doit fournir le
carburant et vivres tant attendu ça fait
maintenant cinq semaines que la caravane
est parti et la crédibilité d'un 12 en
tant qu'organisateur de l'expédition
dépend de ce rendez-vous la confiance
que mes hommes ont placé en mon jugement
est en ma capacité à les ramener sain et
sauf
me fais prendre toute la mesure de la
responsabilité que j'ai robert e
la caravane arrive en temps et en heure
la satisfaction est immense pour le
responsable de l'expédition
la caravane tout entière est apparu avec
son chef arborant le drapeau américain
elle a majestueusement parcouru la
vallée c'était une vision enivrante une
sensation émouvante jeu pub pour la
toute première fois me rendre compte que
l'expédition était un succès
ce fut un moment clé dans ma vie
andrews son épouse et le cinéaste
shackleford font à présent route vers
huerga pour demander au gouvernement
mongol l'autorisation de s'enfoncer
encore plus loin dans le désert il
assiste alors à une magnifique fête
bouddhiste que chaque ford filmera
mais le voyage s'arrête là pour madame
en 12 le conservateur du muséum a fait
savoir depuis new york qu'yvette ne
devait pas pénétrer davantage dans ce
pays déchiré par les guerres
cher monsieur amoureuse vous allez
prendre de gros risques
madame anne russe ne doit pas
entreprendre ce dangereux périple avec
vous croyez moi
alors qu'yves est fait route vers pékin
en 12 rejoint l'expédition où il
apprendra qu aucune découverte n'a été
faite en son absence
le temps est précieux en dessous c'est
que dans ce désert un froid glacial
succède à la chaleur accablante
près d'un lac aux abords de sagan nord
le découragement ne se fait pas
ressentir le gibier abondent les hommes
sont heureux et confiant même les
voitures fonctionnent à merveille
l'expédition souhaite ramener avec elles
des fossiles mais également les
représentants d'espèces vivantes rare le
moindre rongeurs présente un intérêt
scientifique
le désert regorge d mione et d'antilopes
un petit hérisson devient même la
mascotte de chaque elford les mammifères
vivant pullulent mais cela fait des
semaines qu aucun fossile de grande
taille n'a été trouvé l'hiver approche
et en 12 craint que son expédition
n'était qu'un échec très onéreux
c'est alors que grainger et chaque
elford découvre un os partiellement
enfouie
il s'agit d'un os de 90 cm de long
appartenant à un grand mammifère du nom
de ballouchy terium jusqu alors on ne
connaissait ce mammifère que grâce à
quelques minuscules fragments d'os
le crâne de l'animal etait-il loin de là
andrews se joint aux fouilles
j'ai déballé le versant escarpé en
hurlant j'avais trouvé un fragment d'os
à moitié enfoui dans le sable lorsque
shekels ford et huang sont arrivés j'ai
pris en train de gratter la terre tel un
chien
nous venions de découvrir le crom d'un
ballouchy terium
andrews demanda grainger de faire
déterrer le reste des ossements grainger
est obligé d'arrêter en 12 qui dans son
excitation à les faire éclater le crâne
en morceaux
c'est la première fois que l'homme peut
contempler de visu le plus gros
mammifères ayant existé sur terre
presque huit mètres de haut un
rhinocéros mesurant trois mètres de plus
qu'une girafe
il pèse 33 tonnes 4 fois le poids d'un
éléphant il s'agit là d'une découverte
spectaculaire un fantôme vieux de 32
millions d'années
mais la découverte a lieu à un moment
critique les journées de canicule et les
limites glacial ont eu raison de la
moitié des réserves de carburant
le 30 août en 12 annonce que la première
saison de fouilles est terminé et qu'il
faut retourner à pékin
mais cette région n'est indiquée sur
aucune carte afin de ne pas gaspiller
des sens andrews part en éclaireur pour
trouver le chemin du retour et quitter
cette région hostile
pour passer le temps le cinéaste
shackleford parcours 1 km en direction
d'un bassin bordée de falaises
flamboyante tard dans l'après midi
ils localisent un objet sur le sol il
s'agit d'un fossile qu'il ne ressemble à
aucun autre
même grainger et déconcerté
en plein milieu de cette étendues
désertes cette falaises de grès rouge
est sur le point de révéler le secret
qu'elle cache depuis 75 millions
d'années
c'est dans cette partie reculée au style
de mongolie qu'à la fin de l'été 1922
une équipe de scientifiques américains
sous la houlette de reuil chapman jews
découvre une falaise regorgeant de
fossiles mais l'hiver approche à grands
pas en douze ne laisse qu'une journée à
ses hommes pour explorer ce trésor
ces falaises de grès rouge s'enflamme
littéralement au coucher du soleil
nous les avons donc appelé fleming cliff
les falaises enflammé
andrews quitte cet endroit mystérieux se
jurant de revenir
nous étions partis vaillant et courageux
conscient que l'expédition était très
risqué ça aurait pu tourner à la
catastrophe mais nous avions gagné
le retour vers la frontière chinoise
s'avère long et périlleux cinq mois
d'exploration auront permis à
l'expédition envoyé par le muséum
américain d'histoire naturelle de
rassembler des tonnes de fossiles preuve
est faite que la voiture est un moyen de
transport fiable pour explorer le désert
de gobi
c'est dans leur palais manchu quand 12
et le paléontologue walter grainger
répertorie les incroyables fruit de leur
première saison sur le terrain
les résultats scientifiques avaient
surpassé nos espoirs les plus fous et
nous savions que ce n'était là qu'un
début nous avions trouvé des squelettes
entiers de dinosaures des fragments de
dinosaures de plusieurs mètres de haut
les crânes de rhinocéros des centaines
de spécimens
à new york
and we fall osbourne est ravi de lire
les télégrammes dans blues il a mis la
réputation du muséum en jeu et il a
gagné
vous venez d'écrire à nouveau chapitre
de l'histoire de la vie sur terre
andrews supplies to les paléontologue du
muséum de le rejoindre
le conservateur osbourne fait preuve de
prudence en promettant d'envoyer trois
hommes en renfort à pékin en 12
impétueux héros du corps diplomatique
passé l'hiver à jouer au polo on père
était un joueur de polo fier agressif
voire féroce
je me souviens d'un joueur anglais de
l'équipe adverse interviewé après la
partie et qui n'avait pu marquer aucun
point
il a dix personnes en auraient marqué
avec fouilleurs de fossiles chauve
toujours en train de vous faire tomber
de cheval
l'expédition atteint le terrain
fossilifère qu'elle avait découvert
l'année précédente les hommes extraits
des ossements de dizaines de dinosaures
empilés les uns sur les autres
selon walter grainger cette région aride
aurait pu autrefois être un lac
tropicale un cimetière datant de l'âge
des reptiles
la plupart des animaux découvert son dea
droz or dinosaure herbivore à bec de
canard de plus de 12 mètres de long que
l'on trouve abondamment en amérique du
nord les à dreux eure et est aussi le
repas favori des tyrannosaures mais la
découverte des cadres aux orres n'est
qu'un début
les américains sont en train de prouver
que la mongolie représente le gisement
de dinosaures fossiles le plus riche
jamais exploré le nombre de reptiles qui
pullulaient dans cette région est
impressionnant
ce monde cauchemardesque du passé s'est
éteint il leur est aujourd'hui que ces
chaînes de montagnes silencieuse et
balayé par le vent dans un désert de
gobi dessécher et brûlé par le soleil
d'été alors qu'il cherche toujours
davantage de fossiles les scientifiques
sont confrontés aux tempêtes de sable
le vent soufflait de plus en plus
bruyamment je compris qu'une terrible
tempête de sable était en train de se
préparer la plaine était en 3d
tourbillon de sable et de vents de plus
en plus violents
puis tout d'un coup la tempête c'est ça
plus le moindre souffle de vent
le silence était pesant après tout ce
bruit et toute cette violence engendrés
par la tempête
les tempêtes sont soudaine et violente
la luminosité éblouissante qui règne
dans le désert a rendu en douce presque
aveugle mi juin 1923 il arrête de tenir
son journal à jour ma vue a tellement
baissé que je dois m'arrêter de lire et
écrire jusqu'à la fin de l'été
l'étape la plus importante 650
kilomètres plus loin aux abords des
flaming lips reste encore à franchir
pour andrews et granger ses falaises
vont permettre de découvrir si oui ou
non la mongolie et bien la plaque
tournante de l'évolution animale
l'expédition dans son ensemble ratissera
le versant des falaises
cette fois ils disposeront pour ce faire
d'un mois complet chaque membre de
l'expédition trouve en l'espace de
quelques heures un fossile de valeur
même en 12 qui pourtant ne voit plus
clair alors que je marchais au fond du
ravin
je vis une pipe à côté d'un rocher
grainger l'avait perdu un an auparavant
et bizarrement il l'avait fait tomber à
quelques centimètres du crâne et des
mâchoires d'un proto ceratops
le proto ceratops était un dinosaure
jusqu'à l'heure inconnues que le
cinéaste shackleford avait par hasard
découvert l'année précédente dans les
falaises flamboyante
c'était un dinosaure qui ne mesurait que
de mettre 75 delon cousin miniature du
gigantesque tricératops d'amérique du
nord
vieux de 75 millions d'années
le proto ceratops vient s'ajouter aux
richesses enseveli du désert de gobi
le lendemain les américains font ce que
l'on considère comme la plus grande
découverte de l'expédition une couvée 2
les explorateurs fasciné pense qu'il
s'agit là de de dinosaure fossilisé nous
arrivions à peine à en croire nos yeux
pourtant ça ne faisait pas l'ombre d'un
doute il s'agissait bien d'offres et
nous étions sûrs que c'était des oeufs
de dinosaures
on
ce sont les premiers oeufs entiers
découvert par des scientifiques
ils viennent confirmer que les
dinosaures étaient bel et bien en vie
par
ces indices seront précieux pour
connaître le mode de reproduction et
d'évolution des dinosaures il y à 75
millions d'années
cette découverte sera de reuil japan on
june la superstars de la science
américaine
s'il réussit à ramener ses hommes sains
et saufs du désert de gobi
août 1923 le chamelier mérine affronte
la chaleur étouffante du désert de gobi
pour essayer désespérément de rejoindre
l'expédition américaine il
approvisionnés en vivres et en carburant
cela fait des semaines que les
scientifiques quasiment à court de
vivres attente au pied des falaises la
caravane de chameaux mais la caravane ne
semble pas venir
andrews se demande si son fidèle mérine
ne s'est pas perdue en chemin ou s'il
n'a pas été assassiné par des bandits
andrews et ses hommes ont trouvé
tellement de fossiles qu'ils viennent à
manquer d'emballage maintenant qu'ils
n'ont plus de plâtre il utilise de la
farine il le tissu se fait également
rare nous avons tout d'abord déchiré
tous les rabats de tentes
ensuite nous nous sommes attaqués aux
serviettes aux gones toilettes et enfin
à nos vêtements
tout le monde a donné quelque chose des
chaussettes des pantalons des chemises
ou même des sous vêtements
la collection contient un magnifique
crâne de dinosaures emballés dans des
bandelettes découpé dans mon pyjama
et
finalement mme erin et les chameaux
arrivent dans le camp épuisé la moitié
du troupeau n'a pas survécu à la faim et
à la fatigue les poils des chameaux
survivants fournissent la matière idéale
pour emballer les fossiles on prend même
le temps de soigner un chameau blessés
aux sabots la caravane reprend
finalement le chemin du retour
transportant 200 caisses de fossiles
après deux saisons passées sur le
terrain
andrews est persuadé que cinq ans
d'exploration ne suffirait même pas à
percer tous les secrets du désert de
gobi
il décide de rentrer à new york afin de
récolter plus d'argent et de jouir de la
faveur des gens riches et célèbres qui
le considérons comme le plus grand
chasseur de dragons la découverte des
oeufs de dinosaures est accueilli comme
le plus grand triomphe d explorateur
américain
cette découverte extraordinaire est la
première du genre dans le monde
scientifique
de retour à new york en 12 organise des
conférences qui connaissent un réel
succès il déclare avoir trouvé le jardin
d'éden sur le sol aride de mongolie nous
avons clairement démontré que l'asie
centrale est le berceau de la vie
animale
c'est sur ce continent que tout a
commencé
pendant ce temps au muséum américain
d'histoire naturelle les oeufs de
dinosaures sont exposés au grand public
new york en raffolent
toute l'amérique est en proie à la dino
magna cette passion pour la préhistoire
envahi tous les domaines de la science à
la science fiction
andrews n'aurait pu choisir meilleur
moment pour récolter des fonds pour ces
fouilles
il sillonne le pays et donne 125
conférence en l'espace de quatre mois
il savait comment s'y prendre pour
récolter des fonds
à cette époque souvenez vous que nous
sommes dans les années 20 il est parvenu
à réunir des centaines de milliers de
dollars ce qui équivaudrait aujourd'hui
à plusieurs millions s'il a réussi c'est
parce qu'il connaissait des gens haut
placés
panju présente conservateur du muséum
and we fait fields bornes un plan
audacieux je suis persuadé que le grand
public est prêt à aider l'expédition
si nous pouvions vendre un des oeufs de
dinosaures aux enchères pour gonfler les
fonds nécessaires à l'expédition
ça ferait beaucoup de publicité une fois
de plus
andrews a raison les offres affluent des
universités de la presse et des
particuliers
c'est le philanthrope austin colgate qui
fait l'offre la plus intéressante avec
5000 $ le coût publicitaires rapporte
pratiquement trois cent trente mille
dollars
malheureusement à son insu ces enchères
vaudront plus tard à rory chapman 12
d'être chassé de son jardin d'éden de
mongolie
elle lui fait fields bornes exigent
davantage de son explorateur vedette
andrews devra mettre l'accent sur la
recherche de semens appartenant au
premier homme
la science soulève à nouveau un problème
qui intéresse un large public dans les
années 20 ce qu'on appelle le chaînon
manquant entre le singe et l'homme fait
l'objet de discussions purement
théorique ou de films hollywoodiens
personne ne sait à quoi ressemble le
chaînon manquant meyreuil chapman jews
se lance à sa recherche
notre prochaine expédition sera tout
spécialement destiné à découvrir
l'endroit où habitait le premier rhum
cette découverte mettra fin une fois
pour toutes à la controverse concernant
l'évolution en mai 1924 le chercheur de
fossiles américain le plus célèbre kit
manhattan à la recherche d' adam et eve
dans le désert brûlant et aride de
mongolie
lorsque wright chapman en 12 vient
chercher auprès du gouvernement
communiste de mongolie extérieure une
autorisation lui permettant une nouvelle
expédition
ce dernier s'y opposent les autorités
ont eu vent qu'à new york
andrews a vendu un oeuf de dinosaure
pour la somme de 5000 $ elle accuse
l'explorateur de détourner des fossiles
appartenant à la mongolie et valant des
millions de dollars après trois semaines
de dures négociations
andrews est autorisée à poursuivre son
expédition
mais des agents mongol le suivront
la tension monte
on remplit les véhicules d'armes et de
munitions les autorités chinoises font
savoir en 12 que des bandits dépouillé
tu des voyageurs sur le plateau de
mongolie mais sa mission est claire il
ne fera pas demi tour
alors qu'il fait ses adieux à son épouse
en 12 craint plus que jamais de ne plus
la revoir
l'exploration est devenue toute sa vie
il avait dû prendre une décision
fonder un foyer et être un bon père de
famille ou être explorateurs et
organiser des expéditions fructueuse
mon père et ma mère est ainsi souvent
séparés leur mariage a commencé à se
désagréger pour finalement se dissoudre
su persuader que ma mère se sentait très
soeur
l'expédition la plus importante de tous
les temps et mise sur pied avec 50
hommes des cartographes un émetteur
radio et même des tenues officielles
andrews découvre bientôt que les
autorités chinoises lui ont fait croire
que des bandits sévices et dans le
désert pour essayer de faire passer des
cargaisons d'armes en pays mongols en
empruntant les routes qu'ils ouvraient
en mai 1925 l'expédition atteint les
flammes inglis découverte deux ans plus
tôt mais cette fois ci l'équipe se lance
sur les traces de l'homme et elle va les
trouver
des silex des racloirs et des pointes de
flèches utilisé par des hommes qui
vivaient là il ya vingt mille ans et
quand jude baptise habitants des dunes
un peuple de l'âge de pierre
proche de l'homme de cro magnon européen
il ne s'agit pas du chaînon manquant
mais preuve est faite que les premiers
hommes ont habité dans les plaines de
mongolie au début du mois d'août
il est temps de se remettre en route
l'expédition n'ayant pas trouvé de
semens humain elle doit chercher des
fossiles à l'est
alors que les jours raccourcissent
andrews quitte les flamming lips
nous avons le vélo quand le 2 août le
coeur gros
cet endroit était de bon augure nous
n'aurions jamais espéré tant du désert
de gobi
nous irons découvert les premiers oeufs
de dinosaures une centaine de grammes et
de squelettes de dinosaures jusqu alors
inconnu et les habitants des dunes sans
doute ne reverrais jamais ses palais
quelques jours plus tard le gouvernement
mongol menace d'expulser l'expédition du
pays
il accuse andrews de dérober des trésors
nationaux et de cacher des espions
américains
oh
confiant et peut-être trop impétueux
angels réfute les accusations
il est pratiquement inutile de nier les
accusations de propagande politique et
d'espionnage militaire qui pèse sur nous
nous sommes des explorateurs pas des
hommes politiques
sa contestation fonctionne alors qu'il
emballe ses trésors en 12 pensent déjà à
1926 et à une nouvelle tentative pour
trouver le chaînon manquant
mais la guerre civile en chine ne lui en
donne pas l'occasion et cas était une
ville malheureux les misérables en proie
aux émeutes sur la misère
je me souviens de cette fois où nous
roulions dans la ville
les gendarmes sont sortis d'une
boucherie entraînant ce chinois par la
natte
ils lui ont coupé la tête juste devant
la voiture de là où j'étais assise il
m'a semblé qu'il utilisait le pneu avant
comme bio mais je ne suis pas bien sûr
ce jour en particulier m'a fait prendre
conscience de ce qui se passait dans la
vie
andrews renvoie son équipe à new york
il restera à pékin pour défendre sa
résidence contre les maraudeurs 30 avril
1926 cher professeur osbourne le nord de
la chine est en plein chaos
je n'ai jamais connu des conditions
aussi difficiles un an plus tard la
situation s'aggrave 7 juillet 1927 cher
professeur j'ai emballé tout nos biens
en cas de pillages
je resterai pour défendre la maison
alors quand jose rêve de retourner sur
le terrain
un grand mystère est en train de se
résoudre sans lui à 40 kilomètres de sa
résidence
d'autres scientifiques découvrent les
dents et le crâne du véritable premier
homme l'homme de pékin
des centaines de milliers d'années
séparent l'homme de pékin
des habitants des dunes de mongolie
l'homme de pékin à 800 mille ans dans
les années 20 il est considéré comme le
plus vieil ancêtre de la race humaine
le fossile trouvé semble corroborer la
thèse de ce board
l'asie est le berceau des bines aux
heures des mammifères géants est
maintenant de l'homme la découverte de
l'homme de pékin motive en blouse en
1928 et 1930
andrews sera enfin dans le désert de
gobi à la recherche de fossiles encore
plus anciens il y trouve des mastodontes
d'autres oeufs de dinosaures mais pas
d'ossements humains
le gouvernement chinois a fini par se
lasser des expéditions provenant de
l'étranger
andrews est expulsé pour de bon pendant
les soixante années qui vont suivre
aucun scientifique américain explorera
le désert de gobi
chapman andrews a réalisé son rêve grâce
à son courage et à son sens des
responsabilités dans le désert aride de
l'une des régions les plus hostiles au
monde
il a donné un nouveau sens aux plus
grands mystères de tous les temps
l'origine de la vie sur terre
un mystère dont la clé peut être encore
enfouis dans le sable du désert de gobi
en 1932 chapman jews est de retour dans
un pays secoué par la crise
le muséum d'histoire naturelle ne peut
plus financer de grandes expéditions
and we fuck phil osborn son mentor et
mécène prend sa retraite
chapman en blues prend alors la tête du
fameux muséum d'histoire naturelle
la grande aventure est terminée mais on
joue c'est qu'il a découvert l'un des
plus importants gisements de fossiles
qui servira aux explorateurs à venir
nous savons aujourd'hui qu'aucun endroit
sur terre n'abritait le véritable jardin
d'éden
les premiers hommes ont migré d'afrique
vers l'asie les dinosaures et les
mammifères ont évolué sur plusieurs
continents
mais on doit beaucoup aux expéditions
menées dans les années 20 dans le désert
de gobi
la mongolie est maintenant connu pour
être le gisement de fossiles le plus
important au monde
75 ans plus tard la mongolie exerce
toujours la même fascination sur les
traces d'un explorateur de génie les
paléontologues ont découvert de précieux
indices sur la vie et l'évolution de ces
gigantesques créatures du passé
m
on